Juan is with us in Miami
hey Juan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey are you better than I deserve what's
up hey so uh I wanted to get your advice
on a decision I'm leaning towards taking
for the holidays so instead of buying my
mom a typical Christmas gift what I want
to do is help out the rest for car loans
about $9,000 and the only thing holding
me back is her main source for her only
source of income and she runs her own
business that's kind of been up and down
these past few years and really down
this last year and she's not doing much
bringing new customers so I've done it
and helped with the time that I can
assist and help bring her business
online giving her a website you know
Google Maps help and I wanted to ask you
is me helping to pay out for car loans
gonna create some sort of trend towards
codependency well it doesn't if you
don't allow it to I mean I didn't hear a
trend so far of codependency all I heard
was you're just trying to hope your mom
get her business going and she doesn't
work it as diligently as you think she
should in different ways but I paid off
a car you know takes some of the
pressure off of her doing business or
working her business but it also kind of
gives you an entree a stepping stone to
conversationally to go hey now that the
cars paid off let's get busy on this
business and let's get this thing going
mom you know that could be a motivator
rather than a demotivator the car being
paid off plus it also gives you you know
I'm gonna pay off the car so that you
could get the business going let's not
stand there and watch it die you know
and you kind of got the right to say
that do you see what I'm saying right
then so I I doesn't have to be
codependent so many codependency is if
she becomes addicted to your money you
know
that's what you want to prevent and but
I think you can decide that at any point
that you didn't mention a pattern
to this point of you supporting her or
taking care of her is there one not
necessarily I guess it's more so that if
I were to pay this loan off you know
I've been helping her pay off some them
so there does you know yeah I guess if
this is a major debt payoff for her I
guess
you have helped her going off other
debts sorry you have helped her pay off
other debts yeah oh okay well then it is
maybe like a credit card or two that's
like okay well III think you know you've
just got to gauge that and if you're
asking the question then you know keep
asking the question am I am I really
helping her because that's what
codependents do they act like they're
helping someone and they do something
nice but it's not helpful because the
person stays in there crazy and that's
not you know that that's a codependent
codependence are the nicest people on
the planet and so um you know you just
want to you just trying to help your mom
I mean it's not a bad thing but we want
to really help her and what really helps
her is not her debt being paid off what
really helps her is her getting her act
together with her income and her outgo
both and if you can help her do that
with this sure it's a wonderful thing to
do so it sounds like you know you've got
a little bit of a history here but I
still don't hear anything that says no
don't do that I mean I probably would
pay it off you've got the money it
sounds like now again I but but the way
to keep it from being codependent is to
attach some expectations to the gift mom
I'm going to do this but I'm expecting
you to get your business going in return
the way you pay me back is you get your
business going you get you let's get
this thing going
let's get a firing your butt here let's
go let's go and just you know start to
however it is you talk to your mom but I
mean you you know you just you tie into
you tie the two things together not a
conditional gift like that but it just
it gives you the the right to speak into
it